[Musique]
bonjour vincent duluc et merci de nous
accorder cet entretien les fans de foot
vous connaissent vous lisent et vous
écoute scrupuleusement vous êtes l'un
des meilleurs connaisseurs du foot
français le foot qui a vraiment souffert
de la crise sanitaire peu de gens le
savent on entend souvent on va pas
pleurer les clubs de ligue 1 on va voir
que c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça y
aura-t-il un foot d'après qu'ovide c'est
la grande question mais ma première
question c'est vous demander comment
vous allez parce que le virus nous a
frappés durement déjà ça va mieux merci
beaucoup c'est une période un peu
difficile j'ai passé 28 jours à
l'hôpital trois semaines en réanimation
donc j'étais un peu plongé dans cette
espèce de tunnel dont on voit
difficilement goût à la pression d'être
happé par quelque chose de complètement
incontrôlable j'ai eu la chance d'être
bien soignés sur la chance d'en être
sorti donc j'en suis évidemment très
heureux et très reconnaissant envers
envers le monde soignants dont on parle
déjà plus maintenant présent à présent
que le que le colcoa vide s'éloigne un
peu et une fois guéri on va y venir vous
avez été soutenue mais
comment vous avez vécu comme amoureux du
foot la fin des matchs la fin des
compétitions
plus rien c'est un peu compliqué c'est
un sentiment un peu schizophrène d'un
côté j'avais envie que tout le monde
fasse attention et prennent soin de sa
santé d'un autre côté j'étais tout à
fait conscient que le fait de pas
reprendre le foot en france était une
grave erreur politique sportive et
économique tout à la fois je pense que
l'erreur politique parce que c'est nier
que la place du sport dans
la société française et c'est une place
que les que nos grands pays voisins
ont su ont su accorder que ça soit
l'angleterre l'espagne et l'italie et
l'allemagne c'est l'erreur économique
parce que le foot français va perdre à
vendre 800 millions et un milliard
d'euros puis c'est une erreur sportive
parce qu'on a des dents quand même dans
un domaine très compétitif où nous nos
voisins bons vont encore accentuer
l'avancé qu'ils ont sur nous alors le 29
mai en fait cette une de l'équipe une
choc avec cette question en titre comme
des cons point d'interrogation alors que
vous l'avez dit l'allemagne le royaume
uni l'espagne et l'italie reprennent les
championnats nous reprend pas vous avez
eu notamment pendant votre convalescence
pas mal de patrons de clubs au téléphone
on a pris cette décision uniquement pour
des raisons sanitaires à votre avis
qu'est ce que vous avez appris sur les
raisons profondes de cette décision non
mais la raison sanitaire et d'exister
elle est véritable évidemment que
reprendre c'était un risque mais on
aurait pu juste gagner un peu de temps
et choisir de choisir de réfléchir le
choisir de ne pas reprendre on a été les
seuls à choisir de ne pas reprendre les
seuls avec la belgique avec les pays bas
je crois qu'il ya après il y avait on
dort gibraltar enfin bref mais ce choix
évidemment n'est pas seulement sanitaire
c'est un choix politique du gouvernement
mais je pense surtout c'est un choix
sportif c'est un choix qui correspond
aux intérêts de certains présidents en
fait des présidents de clubs se sont
alliés pour figer le classement parce
qu'il était bénéficiaire de ce
classement la preuve en creux c'est que
jean michel aulas qui lui n'était pas
bénéficiaire de reclassement s'est battu
depuis le départ ne pas trop en faire en
sorte pour faire en sorte que le
championnat reprenne donc en fait ceux
qui avaient un intérêt c'était ce qui
était en tête de classement évidemment
en tête de classement ou dans le cloud
en l'aidant les places européennes qui
donne accès à une coupe d'europe
ou dans des situations de bas de tableau
il était en danger de descendre en ligue
2 et le fait que le classement soit figé
leur permettait de sauver donc oui
effectivement il ya eu une agrégation
d'intérêts particuliers qu'on a qu'on a
déjà un peu habillée ou maquillée sous
des prétextes d'intérêt général
d'empocher une connerie clairement pour
moi oui pour moi c'est pour moi c'est
une grosse bêtise et je regrette
beaucoup que ce débat-là était
complètement happé par la
personnalisation justement du débat
autour de jean michel aulas alors
c'était un débat d'ordre général jean
michel aulas qui lui étaient contre
cette décision et qui a milité sans
succès jusqu'au bout pour que après la
suspension reprennent comme nos voisins
européens et vous avez cette phrase dans
l'édito de cette même une cette
exception en europe souligne la place du
sport dans ce pays son manque de
reconnaissance en tant que culture on
n'a pas la culture du sport d'en
attraper non je pense qu on a confondu
depuis 1998 la culture de la victoire et
la culture du sport c'est à dire que ce
qui nous intéresse descendre dans la rue
et de fêter les victoires françaises
mais le sport c'est autre chose c'est la
victoire c'est la défaite d'ailleurs
l'écrivain anglais nick hornby a
toujours dit que l'essence de la vie de
supporters s'étaient c'était la
déception donc le sport c'est au delà de
ça et c'est quelque chose en france qui
est qui est trop récent pour être pour
être vraiment un pain a planté on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui le sport devient un
peu plus une culture mais il n' y est
quand même en tant qu'important spa par
son ministre lui même c'est à dire que
roxana marie cn maracineanu pardon
l'ancienne championne du monde de
natation qui était secrétaire d'état aux
sports a elle même dit que le sport
n'était pas prioritaire puis ont pu
ensuite elle a 10 mai en allemagne vous
rendez compte ils reprennent le
championnat pour des raisons économiques
mais pour quelle autre raison le
déconfinement at il été décidé c'est
bien pour sauver l'économie et ce qu'on
accorde à la vraie vie on n'accorde pas
aux sports et c'est ça qui me déçoit
c'est ça qui me navre on a entendu des
arguments sur le huis clos comme étant
la dénaturation de la même du foot vous
n'êtes pas d'accord mais c'est assez
particulier parce que ceux qui
reprochent au foot de jouer à huis clos
en disant effectivement ça spectacle
dénaturer c'est ça aussi qui reprochent
au foot d'être venu un spectacle donc en
fait le foot à huis clos au contraire
c'est plutôt le foot originelle c'est
plutôt le foot de la cour de récréation
c'est le foot de dans le pré derrière la
maison on se retrouve juste les joueurs
contre les joueurs alors évidemment
c'est un peu habillée d'artifice avec le
bruit des supporters qui ont été pré
enregistré et qui sont actionnées par
des des espèces de dj de chaque club qui
met les sifflets les applaudissements
les regrets y un peu tout ça mais ça
reste un spectacle et se trouve que moi
je trouve que c'est mieux que rien voilà
c'est déjà mieux que rien alors la
conséquence principale de cet arrêt
prolongé des championnats de ligue 1
c'est que le robinet des droits télé
s'est tari il a été fermé quelles
conséquences économiques parce qu'on a
l'impression que ça va bien
économiquement le foot média toute une
filière de métier derrière est ce que
est ce qu elle a été impactée c'est
compliqué de dire que le que les droits
télé que la famille soit d'euros tv sont
la conséquence de l'arrêt parce qu'ils
ont été aussi une des causes de l'arrêt
à dire qu'à partir du moment où canal+ a
décidé de ne pas verser tous les droits
jusqu'à la fin de la saison parce que le
championnat s'était arrêté ça a été une
raison plus de pas reprendre le
championnat mais ce qui est vrai c'est
quelle vraie dépendance
des clubs français vis-à-vis des droits
télé ou des que mondiaux en général bien
c'est 60% c'est ça
ça dépend des clubs c'est à dire que par
rapport au psg effectivement c'est
beaucoup moins et par rapport à un club
de fin de tableau ça peut être
effectivement 60% du budget voilà c'est
une vraie subventions donc quand ça
s'est coupé bien plus d'argent voilà
c'est un peu compliqué c'est difficile
de plaindre les footballeurs eux mêmes
parce que maintenant ils ont des gros
salaires mais il faut pas confondre
effectivement les footballeurs et leurs
gros salaires et la filière tout
ensemble parce que la filière c'est que
les employés des clubs qui ont vraiment
des petits salaires cdc les journalistes
on se rend compte aujourd'hui qu'il ya
des plans à rmc et à l'équipe c'est
voilà il ya il ya toute une filière fait
des fédérations qui pèse ti pas ti de
ces deux sets les fédérations encore si
on peut faire une parenthèse que la
fédération française de foot c'est là on
voit aussi que l'arrêt du foot est un
problème de gouvernance terre que la
ligue de football professionnel qui gère
le foot professeurs professionnels a été
complètement dépassé par ses propres
président qui ont décidé l'arrêt et
pendant ce temps-là fait la fédération
française de football dirigée par noël
le graet et qui chapeaute où le foot à
elle conserver ses intérêts particuliers
en maintenant la finale de la coupe de
france et le monde rendu public alors
qu'il était pour l'arrêt et puis en
organisant huit matchs de l'équipe de
france à l'automne ce qui serait un
record ce qui fait que dans ce cas là
c'est pour rappeler que chacun a défendu
ses intérêts sauf l'intérêt général
ce qu'il peut y avoir des clubs qui vont
mettre la clé sous la porte et faillite
de clubs en france sachant qu'il ya
quand même des add 1 200 millions sur la
table de données par le gouvernement
plus qu'une aide c'est ainsi infligé
ainsi après garantis par l'état donc il
fera quand même le rembourser sans doute
sur les droits télé mais c'est vrai que
ça pouvait dire soit un club je pense
qu'en ligue 1 on va éviter les faillites
parce que l'udc le club le plus endetté
c'est l'olympique de marseille à hauteur
d'environ 200 millions d'euros mais on
sait que un repreneur ou même le
propriétaire peut tout à fait que
combler combler ce vide la difficulté
c'est les clubs professionnels de ligue
2 de deuxième niveau et dans d'autres
sports comme en rugby ou effectivement
ça peut être très violent
on comprend bien qu on a fait un choix
qu un peu contre tous les autres même
s'il ya quelques exceptions vous l'avez
dit quand ils l'ont vécu les joueurs
alors vous êtes un des rares
journalistes qui leur parle et ça a eu
pas mal de contacts dans les clubs
comment on vit quand tout s'arrête les
entraînements est ce qu'on a peur de de
baisser en qualité de jeu je pense que
les joueurs ils ont été comme tout le
monde ils ont ils ont dès que ça de
manière d'abord replier un peu pas
égoïste mais un peu repliés c'est à dire
qu'ils sont intéressés à leur santé à la
santé de leurs proches ils sont
intéressés ils sont intéressés à leur
intérêt pour promettre notamment pour
maintenir leur salaire donc après les
joueurs il adore jouer donc y moi de
content de reprendre mais je ne pense
pas que ça les est profondément
traumatisé à part ceux qui effectivement
qu'ils avaient des raisons familiales de
vivre cette période de manière assez
anxiogène qui ne pensait que la qualité
du jeu puisque il ya une nouvelle saison
qui va démarrer en août la qualité de
jeu va baisser je pense pas que la
qualité du jeu va baisser en france
parce qu'au contraire il y aura une
telle envie de jeu qui peut y avoir
quelque chose de de leurs fans et des
retrouvailles et de l'euphorie mais en
revanche la qualité comparé du jeu va
être un problème parce qu'au mois d'août
quand la ligue des champions de la
saison en cours va reprendre avec les
huitièmes de finale et les quarts de
finale les deux représentants français
le pg et lyon n'auront pas de match
compétitif derrière eux alors que les
italiens les allemands les anglais et
les espagnols ont un mois de compétition
et là il y aura une vraie rupture
d'équité les qui aura été choisi par les
français eux-mêmes
donc on risque quand même de subir un
déclassement nous c'est à dire le foot
français la ligue 1 oui il ya un vrai
risque d'accès un double des classements
ça déclassement sportive parce
qu'effectivement on sera moins
compétitifs probablement en ligue des
champions même si bon il faut être
honnête on les a rarement été toutes
toutes ces années là et on sera encore
moins compétitifs sportivement et
économiquement à la rentrée parce que
les clubs français vont être obligés de
vendre leurs meilleurs joueurs encore
plus que d'habitude justement pour
pouvoir équilibrer les comptes renflouée
par à la vente de joueurs on est un peu
la salle d'entraînement des autres clubs
en europe c'est ça oui ou leur centre de
formation où leur vivier en tout cas
mais effectivement les joueurs français
sont bien formés donc ils réussissent à
l'étranger et donc chaque année le
championnat de france est affaiblie mais
risque de l'être encore plus cette année
ce qui s'est passé totalement inédit
dans dans le pays sur la planète et donc
pour le foot également le foot d'après
ça existe ça doit exister ça vous fait
sourire oui parce que j'ai peur qu'on
soit déjà dans le foot de près depuis
quelques temps et qu'on soit déjà allés
au maximum de ce qu'on peut tolérer en
termes de commercialisation de foot en
termes de de marchandisation il faudrait
le modèle économique moi moi ce que
j'aimerais salaires des joueurs
j'aimerais qu'on voit au moins un
système de transfert comment le système
de transfert sont un peu plus vertueux
aujourd'hui c'est juste un prétexte pour
faire circuler beaucoup d'argent et que
beaucoup d'intermédiaires capte une
grande partie de cet argent on voit
qu'aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup d'argent dans le foot qui
qui qui va dans des poches voudraient
atterrir et c'est les poches parfois des
agents qui ont fait leur travail pour
placer un joueur mais aussi aussi des
poches parfois des dirigeants voire même
des entraîneurs qui sont intéressés aux
départs de certains joueurs donc là il
faudrait vraiment voyez rendre les
transferts un peu plus vertueux mais ce
que c'est possible tu as plus de
sobriété
financière dans dans le foot sachant que
s'il ya bien un sport mondialisée c'est
celui là mais j'y crois pas parce que
pour ce soit possible il faudrait que la
fifa qui est de la fédération
internationale du foot
et son gouvernement supranational et non
s'en empare et je pense pas qu'elle le
fera et la moralisation pourrait venir
que pays par pays mais on voit ce que
cette période nous a appris où nous a
confirmé c'est que chacun défende et ses
intérêts avec personne habilis de vision
globale donc ya pas de raison que dans
le monde d'après tout d'un coup
quelqu'un dise
tant pis pour des intérêts vivent là
dessus de l'intérêt général ça
n'arrivera pas il paraît même que
certains joueurs ont touché le chômage
partiel c'est vrai ça l'état à payer les
joueurs français bien sûr bien sûr si
mais c'est arrivé dans la plupart des
sports professionnels 7e 1 on va dire un
mécanisme de sauvetage pour des sports
mais pour le basket pour le
rallonger mais mais mais pour les pour
les joueurs de ligue 1 effectivement ça
n'a pas de sens ça n'a pas de sens alors
je sais que certains l'ont fait mais
c'est pas c'est pas la majorité parce
que c'est pas du tout l'esprit du
chômage partiel effectivement donc vous
vous pourriez nous destinée c'est ma
dernière question le foot de demain que
vous aimeriez
le problème c'est que là aujourd'hui
après après une si longue privation et
même si je suis passé par des moments
qui m'ont fait voir les choses autrement
le monde de demain j'ai passé en vie qui
ressemble au monde d'avant en fait j'ai
vraiment envie de retourner au stade de
retourner à londres d'aller voir de
pouvoir entrer au match de mêler aux
gens
de boire une bière avant un match dans
un peu mais depuis d'aller manger un
morceau derrière avec avec des copains
ou avec des confrères et de retrouver
cette villa est ce que est ce qu'il faut
que ces délits soit plus vertueuse
sûrement mais si on peut recommencer à
la partager déjà ça serait beau merci
merci beaucoup vincentelli que j'ai tout
compris
[Musique]